foreign
[Music]
Square many lines in Ukraine's recent
history intersect
today they honor a fallen fighter killed
on the front line in the east
[Music]
Russia's invasion is only the latest
Milestone on Ukraine's journey to try
and Escape its neighbor's influence
this square has seen tears of joy and
tears of Anguish from the orange
Revolution against Russian influence in
2004 and five to the demonstrations that
began here exactly nine years ago
against the pro-russian government's
decision then to turn its back on the
European Union
in this recent past two brothers have
played significant Parts
afghanistan-born Mustafa and masi nayem
one a lawyer and soldier who lost his
eye fighting in June this year the other
a politician whose Facebook post calling
people to the maidan in November 2013
was the Catalyst for much of what has
happened since
so our generation at that moment said no
if you compare what happened that days
and you compare what's going on now is
the same emotions is the same intentions
and the main reason is what people
wanted to be independent Mustafa now a
government Minister chose politics and
civil resistance
foreign
Instinct was to take up arms
Justice for me is very big thing because
I remember Afghanistan I remember
how we don't have a power
to defend ourselves
and in Ukraine we have this power I
speak with myself and I say for myself
that
I don't go to die for these values I go
to fight for these values because if you
were if you go to die for some values
one day it's gonna be
that you die but when you fight
yeah one day you win
two brothers fighting for the same cause
in different ways whose stories also
intersect on kiev's Central Square
where under fresh snow the dead from
eight years of fighting are remembered
along with civilian protesters killed in
a hail of police bullets people who'd
answered that Facebook post calling on
them to defend democracy on the Square
that some say embodies the soul of
Ukraine
Jonah Al Jazeera Kiev